frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen kollegen bastian
parlamentarischer tag wortes gegen heute
morgen um den haushalt meines hauses des
bundesministeriums für arbeit soziales
bildung soziale sicherheit das regierung
den mindestlohn es ging um den
bundeshaushalt insgesamt es geht um
äußere sicherheit jetzt geht es um
sicherheit im alter um die renten meine
damen und herren diese bundesregierung
macht mit dem heutigen tag und die sie
tragende koalition deutlich innere und
äußere sicherheit meine damen und herren
und soziale sicherheit das sind keine
gegensätze das machen wir gleichzeitig
und das ist gut für deutschland
doch das sehr grundsätzlich wird der
regierungsklausur in meseberg die
finnische und die schwedische
ministerpräsident zu gast hatten es ging
natürlich um den nato beitritt dieser
beiden bisher neutralen staaten aber
diese beiden staaten machen auch sehr
deutlich dass man ein starker
wohlfahrtsstaat sein kann und
gleichzeitig sich für äußere sicherheit
gewappnet hat und das machen wir heute
in deutschland auch deutlich mit dem
vorliegenden gesetz meine damen und
herren geht es in erster linie um
stabilität es geht um die rentenerhöhung
in diesem jahr zum ersten juli werden
die renten im westen um 5,3 prozent
steigen im osten um 6,1 prozent das ist
gerade in diesen zeiten eine wichtige
nachricht weil es eine der größten
renten der letzten jahrzehnte damen und
herren und was haben sich die rentnerin
westdeutschen blieben
aber dass noch deutlich das ist eben
kein
gnadenerweis des staates ist sondern die
rentenerhöhung die jetzt so kräftig
möglich sind folgen einer guten
entwicklung am arbeitsmarkt und endlich
auch wieder angemessene lohnerhöhung das
ist mir wichtig meine damen und herren
weil diese rentenerhöhungen trat in
dieser zeit wichtig ist weil es einst
auch deutlich machen wir werden und wir
dürfen die entwicklung der renten für
alle generationen niemals von der
lohnentwicklung und entwicklung des
arbeitsmarktes abkoppeln muss werden wir
sorgen aber nicht nur für
verlässlichkeit durch diese
rentenerhöhung wir sagen auch für
stabilität im system ich sage das
ausdrücklich weil wir mit dem gesetz das
heute beschlossen werden soll auch den
sogenannten nachholfaktor wieder
einführen der nachholfaktor ist die
kehrseite der rentengarantie und das
prinzip ist in guten zeiten in
schlechten zeiten wenn die wirtschaft in
deutschland einbricht wird es in
deutschland niemals rentenkürzungen
geben das ist auch richtig so und es
wird dann wenn die zeiten besser werden
im verhältnis von arbeitsmarkt und
beitragszahlern zu retten und rentnern
einen fairen interessenausgleich
zwischen den rentnerinnen und rentnern
und den beitragszahlern eben ich glaube
dass es gut fürs system das ist
verlässlich und das ist ein fairer
interessenausgleich auch zwischen den
generationen dass es
generationengerechtigkeit
aber vor allen dingen schaffen wir mit
diesem gesetz etwas was seit jahren
liegen geblieben ist und was wir das
finde ich ganz offen sagen in der
letzten legislaturperiode mit cdu/csu
leider nicht bewegen konnten es ist mir
ein herzensanliegen dass wir mit diesem
gesetz endlich dafür sorgen dass die
erwerbsgeminderten im bestand bessere
leistungen bekommen meine damen und
herren das ist ein ganz wichtiger
sozialer fortschritt
steht immerhin
größe nicht so als hätten sie das letzte
legislaturperiode gewollt ich habe ja im
kanzleramt gesessen und gefragt können
wir das angehen und das war mit cdu/csu
und nicht möglich ich kann mich erinnern
wie sie die grundrente versucht haben
klein zu machen und zu verhindern auch
hier müssen wir gegen sie durchsetzt
darauf bin ich stolz bewerbs minderung
hinrich bemüht
ich will ihnen eins sagen mir ist nicht
wichtig vorschläge zu machen wie es
wichtig dass wir konkret was für
menschen bewegen das tun wir es werden
drei millionen menschen die
erwerbsgemindert sind das sind menschen
die in lebtag gearbeitet haben den
unfall hatten die zum beispiel der sich
eine behinderung eingeholt haben durch
die arbeit oder die einschränkungen
haben die auf erwerbsminderung
angewiesen sind die kriegen endlich
deutlich mehr leistung 3 millionen
menschen meine damen und herren das ist
sozialer fortschritt für deutschland
mit dem heutigen tag sorgen wir also für
stabilität und verlässlichkeit in der
rente die rente wird steigen zum ersten
juli um 5,3 prozent im westen und 61
prozent im osten der republik und wir
gehen damit übrigens auch ein schritt
zur rentenangleichung ost west wir
sorgen für systemische stabilität durch
nachholfaktor und rentengarantie und wir
verbessern die sozialen leistungen das
ist sozialer fortschritt für
erwerbsgeminderte ich will aber auch
deutlich sagen dass dieses renten paket
der erste schritt ist in dieser
legislaturperiode wir haben große
aufgaben vor uns wir wollen dafür sorgen
als ampelkoalition das auch über 2025
hinaus die gesetzlichen renten durch
eine stabilisierung des rentenniveaus
dauerhafter bleiben für alle
generationen und wir werden gemeinsam
das sage ich richtung fdp das machen was
der beschrieben haben nämlich eine
kapitalreserve aufzubauen die
langfristig die beiträge auch
stabilisiert diese koalition sorgt mit
einem starken sozialstaat dafür dass
sich alle generationen auf die
gesetzliche rente verlassen können davon
können sie ausgehen meine damen und
herren herzlichen dank
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil hat
wir eben auch einmal
eine rentenanpassung verteidigt auf den
antworten wird nun steht
die kolleginnen und kollegen kennen sie
die refrainzeile von ganz schön feist es
ist gut wenn du weißt was du willst wenn
du nicht weißt was du willst ist das
nicht so gut
warum kommt mir das in den sinn wenn wir
heute das rentenanpassung gesetz
debattieren weil man den eindruck hat
dass die koalitionsfraktionen in
rentenfragen einfach nicht wissen was
sie wollen und das ist nicht so gut
ihr koalitionsvertrag ist nach nur sechs
monaten von makulatur sie wollten in
diesem jahr 10 milliarden euro aus
bundesmitteln für den aufbau eines
kapitalstocks aufwenden als einstieg in
die kapitaldeckung von diesen zehn
milliarden war in den
haushaltsverhandlungen diese woche keine
rede mehr sie sind einfach verschwunden
wissen sie vielleicht wo sie geblieben
sind oder wollen sie gar keine reformen
das wäre nicht gut so
lieber herr als arbeitsminister der
großen koalition haben sie 2009 10 für
vier jahre jeweils 500 millionen
sonderzahlung zur stabilisierung der
rentenversicherung gesetzlich
zugesichert an ihr eigenes gesetz fühlen
sie sich als arbeitsminister der ampel
nicht mehr gebunden ihnen ist ihr
bürgergeld wichtiger deswegen zweigen
sie die zwei milliarden zur
stabilisierung der rentenversicherung
kurzerhand für ihr bürgergeld projekt ab
im referentenentwurf ihres hauses stand
das auch ehrlich drin im gesetz dass wir
heute beschließen fehlt diese
ehrlichkeit für das bürgergeld stellen
sie eine stabile finanzierung der
rentenversicherung hinten an sie
riskieren damit ihren ruf als seriöser
politiker wenn man nicht weiß worauf man
sich verlassen kann ist das nicht so gut
dass man sich bei der rente nicht auch
die an verlassen kann zeigt sich auch an
dieser stelle der fdp zuliebe
reaktivieren sie bei der rentenanpassung
für dieses jahr den
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor mit dem
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor wird eine
steigerung der renten nachtrag
nachträglich abgemildert wenn das denn
im vorjahr das allgemeine lohnniveau
gesunken ist das ist ein ausgleich für
die rentengarantie das finden sie gut
schon ab dem nächsten jahr wird der
gerade wieder eingeführte
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor aber schon wieder
wirkungslos bleiben
nachholfaktor wenn sie
einseitig die haltelinie von 48%
rentenniveau zementieren was wollen sie
eigentlich
ich sage ihnen was sie wollen sie wollen
die solidarität in der
sozialversicherung aufkündigen sie
wollen einseitig die jüngere generation
der beitragszahler und der steuerzahler
belasten sie wollen schleichen das
modell einer steuerfinanzierten rente
anstreben weil sie sich vor den
verteilungskonflikten mit blick auf
demografischen wandel und
generationengerechtigkeit fürchten
stecken sie den kopf in den sand sie
verweigert die notwendige debatte um
eine nachhaltige reform der
alterssicherung
und dabei haben wir gar kein
erkenntnisproblem denn in der renten-
kommission der letzten legislatur ist
gut vorgearbeitet worden nun müsse die
andere jetzt ihre hausaufgaben erledigen
und transparente entscheidungsprozesse
gestalten sie dürfen nicht das eine
sagen und das andere machen sie dürfen
sich nicht von einzelnen
interessenslagen leiten lassen sondern
das gemeinwohl muss den ausschlag geben
wenn sie wissen was sie wollen man sagt
es auch ehrlich denn sonst ist das
nämlich nicht gut neben aller kritik das
gute am rentenanpassung gesetz ist neben
der pauschale erhöhung der
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand die
höhe der rentenanpassung von gut 6 und 5
prozent in ost und westdeutschland
diese größte rentenerhöhung seit 30
jahren ist das verdienst der guten
arbeitsmarkt- und wirtschaftspolitik der
unions geführten vorgängerregierungen
eines robusten arbeitsmarktes und seiner
stabilisierung während der korona
pandemie
rentnerinnen und hätten haben diese
rentenerhöhung verdient sie reicht aber
nicht aus um die folgen der massiv
gestiegenen inflation abzufedern und
dann verweigern sie den rentnerinnen und
rentnern auch noch die 300 euro
energiepreis pauschale wie sie in der
nrw-wahl gemerkt haben ist das nicht so
gut
meine damen und herren im unterschied zu
diesen ampel gehampel wissen wir was wir
wollen und das ist eine verlässliche
rentenpolitik deswegen stimmen wir der
anpassung trotz des fragwürdigen
gesetzgebungsverfahrens zu am montag
öffentliche anhörung dienstagabend
außerplanmäßige ausschusssitzung und am
heutigen freitag beschluss im plenum das
war selbst ihren ampel kollegen im
ausschuss beinlich vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
stephan annacker aus der unionsfraktion
und mit ein ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales wie auch der nächste redner
markus kurth spricht nun für bis 90 die
grünen im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen herr doktor nacke sie haben
eben gesagt sie als cdu wissen was sie
wollen in der rentenpolitik ehrlich
gesagt nach dieser rede ich weiß es
nicht also kam sie nicht gesagt was sie
wollen und
es ist ja traurig genug dass
einer der vielleicht größten
rentenpolitischen leistungsausweitungen
und verbesserungs schritte in dieser
legislatur jetzt am ende dieses tages
eines ereignisreichen tages kommt und
dass die verbesserungen bei der
erwerbsminderungsrente
in der presse wahrscheinlich im schatten
des mindestlohns und noch mehr des
sondervermögens der bundeswehr stehen
das ist traurig eher werden wir daran
arbeiten dass ins öffentliche
bewusstsein zu bringen aber da hätte ich
dann doch von einem redner der union die
immerhin zustimmt der doktor nackte die
immerhin zustimmt er doch danach hätte
ich doch mal erwartet dass etwas mehr
jetzt geht er weg das etwas mehr als 1
halbsatz für die erwerbsminderungsrente
abfällt
denn in der tat ist das ein punkt der
drei millionen menschen zwischen 50 und
100 euro im monat mehr bringt das kommt
vielen nicht viel vor aber es sind
renten erwerbsminderungsrentner rinnen
und rentner die renten von im schnitt an
die 800 euro nur haben und da machen 100
euro eine ganze menge aus
und komm jährlichen gesamtvolumen ist
das auch nur sehr beachtliche summe
nämlich 2,6 milliarden euro werden pro
jahr in diesem bereich gezahlt man muss
sich jetzt natürlich überlegen und das
haben wir auch innerhalb der
koalitionsfraktionen natürlich
diskutiert ob wenn man sich das
sicherungsniveau der
erwerbsminderungsrente anguckt das auf
dauer auch ausreichend ist die
erwerbsminderungsrente hat nach andere
einkommensersatz funktion als die
altersrente auf den eintritt des alters
oder darauf das langlebigkeitsrisiko was
dahinter steht kann man sich schließlich
vorbereiten man kann ansparen das kommt
nicht unerwartet zumindest theoretisch
nicht alle können privat vorsorgen eine
erwerbsminderung tritt aber unerwartet
und schnell ein
unfreiwillig und gegen die kann man sich
nicht privat in irgendeiner weise
absicherung absichern und darum brauchen
wir perspektivisch in der
erwerbsminderungsrente
eine absicherung des einkommens risikos
des risikos des lohn verlustes und ein
sicherungsniveau brauchen wir was
vergleichbar ist mit dem in der
arbeitslosenversicherung oder mit dem
krankengeld
das ist leider das ist leider jetzt in
diesem ersten schritt den wir gemacht
haben nicht gelungen aber eine reihe von
gutachtern legt nahe dass wir in die
richtung die ich gerade skizziert hatte
dass wir in diese richtung gehen sollen
uns das sicherungsniveau angucken unter
dem gesichtspunkt welche funktion hat
eigentlich die erwerbsminderungsrente
welches risiko muss abgesichert werden
und ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn wir
in einer konstruktiven zusammenarbeit
und diesen fragen noch einmal zu wenden
in zukunft und auch einer der vorschläge
die die anhörung hervorgebracht hat war
die einrichtung einer
erwerbsminderungsrente kommission das
hört sich ein bisschen sperrig an findet
man vielleicht einen schöneren begriff
aber ich finde es sehr gut wenn wir in
einer kleineren konzentrierten
arbeitsgruppe uns den fragestellungen
des sicherungsniveau es noch mal widmen
und wenn es dann gelingt noch mal einen
aufschlag in dieser legislaturperiode zu
macht und
da hoffe ich auch dass die fdp sich dem
nicht verschließt weil es ja leute sind
die echt was geleistet haben das ist
eine besondere gruppe und ich hoffe auch
dass die fdp sich dem dann nicht
verschließt wenn wir so etwas machen
weil wir mit der wiedereinführung des
nachholfaktor es ja an dieser stelle
auch etwas machen was insbesondere das
dringende politische anliegen der fdp
war es handelt sich nach den
berechnungen des dgb sowie der dgb es in
der anhörung vorgetragen hatte immerhin
um eine aus fdp sicht entlastung der
beitragszahler von 18 milliarden euro
man kann auch von einnahmeverlusten der
rentenversicherung von 18 milliarden
euro sprechen das wäre dies wäre die
andere perspektive aber
die schiere zahl zeigt schon es ist
nicht nichts so wie die union und der
herr doktor nacker der jetzt im
plenarsaal leider gottes bereits vor da
ist er wieder acht tschuldigung
entschuldigung
und haben so jedenfalls so wie die union
behauptet sowie die union behauptet ist
ist nicht nichts sondern die
wiedereinführung des nachholfaktor es
ist ein ziemlich wesentliches element
von dem was wir hier heute beschließen
werden und in diesem sinne hoffe ich
dass das nicht hinten runter fällt die
sehr wichtige erhöhung des mindestlohns
und die wichtigen sicherheitspolitischen
debatten die wir heute hatten spielen
sicherlich ihre rolle aber alle ausgaben
die wir für die äußere sicherheit
tätigen sind sinnlos wenn uns der
gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt und die
soziale sicherheit in diesem lande
zerrinnen und zerbrechen das wäre
das wäre in gewisser weise eine ironie
der geschichte
die wir den mordlüsternen diktatoren auf
dieser erde nicht gönnen dürfen wir
müssen weiter fortfahren äußere und
innere sicherheit und solidität
miteinander zusammen zu bringen vielen
dank
der afg fraktion geht diese
rentenanpassungen nicht weit genug und
deswegen hat sie heute hier auch einen
antrag eingebracht in dem sie fordert
dass es mindestens eine zahlung von 300
euro auch noch einmal einmalig für
energiekosten geben soll und für die afg
spricht jetzt kehre tui
sehr geehrte damen und herren heute soll
das rentenanpassung gesetz verabschiedet
mit werden mit dem eine formal höheren
erhöhung von 0 5 bzw 6 prozent erfolgt
leider nicht aber auch die
inflationsrate schon heute höher als
dies so dass die kaufkraft der renten
trotz dieser durchaus erheblichen
erhöhung weiter sinkt wir unterstützen
zwar die geplante rentenerhöhung
vollumfänglich so holt die lange
überfällige erhöhung im bestand
erwerbsminderungsrente als auch die
erhöhung der altersrenten hätten uns
aber angesichts des drastischen
preisanstieg gerade auch im warenkorb
der rentner mehr gewünscht
der erste mangel sie kündige jetzt eine
rentenerhöhung für die lang vergessene
bestands erwerbsminderungsrentner an
aber in kraft treten sollte diese
erhöhung erst in 2024
während alle anderen rentner schon ab
juli mehr rente zur verfügung haben
müssen ausgerechnet die älteren
jahrgänge der erwerbsminderungsrentner
noch ganze zwei jahre darauf warten auf
die angekündigten verbesserungen und bis
dahin sie glänzt durch die inflation
verpufft
begründet wird das mit technischen
umsetzungsproblemen für deren lösung
erst in 2024 genügend kapazität bei der
rentenversicherung zur verfügung stehen
soll
also für bestimmte
erwerbsminderungsrentner jahrgänge den
prozentsatz heraufzusetzen das geht erst
in zwei jahren
bleibt man sich doch erstaunt die augen
meine damen und herren sie sparen hier
an der falschen stelle
das mindeste aber ist doch dass sie die
rentenerhöhung dann in 2024 wenigsten
nachzahlen aber auch das ist bisher
nicht geplant zum zweiten mangel war die
inflations entlassungs paketen hat die
ampel regierung die rentner nahezu
komplett vergessen rentner ohne
grundsicherung oder wohngeld fallen
einfach unter den tisch dazu gehören
übrigens auch die gut eine millionen
rentner die zwar anspruch auf
grundsicherung hätten also nach allen
kriterien wirklich arm sind die diese
grundsicherung aber nicht beantragt
haben und gerade diese rentner hätten
das entlastungspaket am allernötigsten
mit unserem antrag wollen wir die
entlastung zulieferer gestern rentner
nachholen sie alle haben ist als
abgeordnete der deutschen bürger in der
hand diesem antrag zuzustimmen und damit
allen rentnern eine erhöhung in höhe ein
entlastungspaket in höhe von 300 euro
steuerfrei zukommen zu lassen hand heben
an der richtigen stelle ist genug um
ihnen die entscheidung zu erleichtern
möchte ich hier noch ein paar fakten zum
abend teil unserer rentner anführen wie
viele sind denn eigentlich an die
europäische statistik sagt sehr viele
anti 30 prozent unserer alten sind arm
und die meisten von ihnen sind
dem letzten alterssicherung bericht der
bundesregierung können sie zudem
mitnehmen das und 30 prozent unserer
leyen stehenden rentner weniger als 1250
euro im monat zur verfügung haben und
sie sollten auch wissen dass in etwa der
hälfte aller alten haushalte die rente
das einzige einkommen ist und nun zu den
alle amtsleiter den rentnern ich zitiere
wirklich aus dem alltag sicherungs
bericht die 20 prozent der haushalte mit
dem niedrigsten einkommen lassen sich
durch eine kombination niedriger
alterssicherung leisten leistungen mit
geringen zusätzlichen einkünften
charakterisieren das ist eine hübsche
umschreibung dafür dass die untersten 20
prozent aller haushalte sucht die gar
nichts haben außer ihrer niedrigen rente
und davon können sich heute kaum doch
vernünftig ernähren geschweige denn am
sozialen leben teilhaben oder in würde
altern
meine damen und können sie mitzunehmen
sich bitte einen druck und stimmen sie
mit ja für unseren antrag dankeschön
wie war das für die fdp-fraktion 21
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner aus
soll von dieser rentenerhöhung
profitieren das ist nicht der fall dann
schließe ich die abstimmung und bitte
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
mit der auszählung zu beginnen das
ergebnis der abstimmung wird ihnen dann
im anschluss an diesen
tagesordnungspunkt
bekannt gegeben und wir führen ihn
kommen in der debatte weiter voran
die nächste rednerin ist anja schulz fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir bringen hier heute einen renten
paket auf den weg das seinen vorgängern
etwas ganz bedeutsames voraus hat den
fokus auf dem generationenvertrag
es ist das erste renten paket seit den
frühen 2000 das nicht nur aus teuren bei
geschenken für die generation 50 besteht
das erste renten paket seit langen bei
dem nicht einseitig die jetzigen und die
künftigen beitragszahler belastet werden
die fdp konnte die koalitionspartner
überzeugen den nachholfaktor wieder zu
aktivieren
die wir sie wieder inkraftsetzung des
naturparkes ist nicht einfach nur eine
maßnahme zur stabilen finanzierung der
rente sondern vielmehr eine überfällige
wiedergutmachung eines folgenschweren
fehler nämlich seine aussetzung den
nachholfaktor bei der
rentenanpassungsformel außen vor zu
lassen bedeutet nämlich nichts anderes
als dass die rentner von krisen im
verhältnis zu den einzahlern
überproportional profitieren das wäre
gerade jetzt wo sich krise an krise bald
unseren sozialen klima in keiner weise
verträglich
das soll aber nicht heißen dass die
rentnerinnen und rentner sich ihre rente
nicht redlich verdient hätten ganz im
gegenteil ich denke dass die größe
rentenerhöhung seit 40 jahren von 60 1
prozent im osten und 53 prozent im
westen auf allgemeines wohlwollen steht
stößt diese menschen haben
jahrzehntelang hart gearbeitet und wir
können ihnen jeden euro den sie jetzt
mehr im portemonnaie haben
und damit das auch so bleibt müssen wir
auch damit aufhören die generationen
gegeneinander auszuspielen
die reaktivierung des nachholfaktor
stärkt den generationenvertrag den
rechte und pflichten gibt es wie bei
allen verträgen auf beiden seiten das
verhältnis ist hier allerdings aus dem
gleichgewicht geraten
dass wir
das wird einem bei berechnung
schmerzlich bewusst die kürzlich in der
süddeutschen zeitung zu lesen waren
nämlich wenn man sich mal folgende
zahlen vor augen führt es wurde abhängig
vom geburtsjahr grob errechnet wie lange
jemand rente beziehen müsste um die
eingezahlten beiträge in etwa wieder
raus zu haben wer zum beispiel stets im
durchschnitt verdient hat 1946 geboren
wurde und mit 65 jahren in rente
gegangen ist hat bereits nach elf jahren
und vier monaten also mit 76 jahren alle
rentenbeiträge eingezahlt hat in form
einer rente wieder zurückerhalten würde
ein heute 17 jähriger mit 67 jahren in
rente gehen müsste dieser allerdings
bereits 85 jahre alt werden um das
gleiche zu erzielen über diesen renten
nachteil spricht kaum jemand
für die jetzigen und zukünftigen
berufsanfänger gibt es sehr große
pflichten denn sie müssen die renten der
generation der baby-boomer finanzieren
und das nicht nur aus ihren
rentenbeiträgen sondern auch aus ihren
steuerzahlungen geld was dann an anderer
stelle fehlt von rechten und pflichten
im sinne von renten auszahlen auf einem
adäquaten niveau können sie derzeit
allerdings nur träumen der nachholfaktor
ist also ein erster schritt zurück zum
generationenvertrag
neben diesem elementaren beitrag zur
generationengerechtigkeit und hätte das
renten paket eine weitere maßnahme die
in der letzten legislaturperiode
komplett auf der strecke geblieben ist
wir haben das gerade schon gehört sie
betrifft eine besonders sozioökonomische
wache gruppe nämlich die der
erwerbsminderungsrentner menschen die
aus gesundheitlichen gründen keine
arbeit mehr nachgehen können um ihren
lebensunterhalt eigenständig zu
bestreiten also diejenigen die in
besonderer weise auf unseren sozialstaat
angewiesen sind mit der verbesserung der
erwerbsminderungsrente im bestand
schaffen wir ein stück mehr anerkennung
für drei millionen
erwerbsminderungsrentner die zwischen
2001 und 2009 10 erstmals eine
erwerbsminderungsrente bezogen haben das
ist lange überfällig
das gesetz unterstützt außerdem eine
durch die pandemie extrem gebeutelte
gruppe die der kulturen medienbranche
existenzängste und planungsunsicherheit
haben zwei jahre lang den alltag vieler
kulturschaffender geprägt umso wichtiger
ist es nun dass durch den
stabilisierungs zuschuss für die
künstlersozialkasse ein signal in ihre
richtung gesendet wird
denn die branche muss erst einmal eine
sie haben wieder auf die beine zu kommen
und sich um sich von den finanziellen
folgen durch die pandemie wieder erholen
zu können und trotz des zuschusses für
die künstlersozialkasse und obwohl wir
so viel geld für die
erwerbsminderungsrente in die hand
genommen haben werden wir durch das
renten paket einsparungen in der
rentenkasse haben so halten wir den
beitrag stabil und so schaffen wir einen
fairen generationenvertrag
anja schulz war das für die fdp-fraktion
nächster redner ist matthias illg war er
ist sprecher für rentenpolitik seiner
fraktion und die linke hat ja auch zwei
änderungsanträge und ein
entschließungsantrag eingebracht
minister roberto style die
lebensmittelpreise steigen rasant die
energiepreise explodieren
darum ist es aberwitzig dass
rentnerinnen und rentner vom energie
gilt ausgenommen sind aber minister
ministerin und staatssekretäre die 300
euro erhalten ändern sie das
die durchschnittliche rente alle 21,2
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner liegt
bei 1000 89 euro vor steuern das ist
viel zu wenig und darum brauchen die
rentnerinnen und rentner gerade jetzt
jeden cent um ihren hart erarbeiteten
lebensstandard zu sichern
sicher 6,12 prozent im osten und 5,35
prozent rentenerhöhung im westen sind
sehr ordentlich aber eigentlich hätten
es 6,6 prozent sein müssen und wer hat
das verhindert dass war die fdp die fdp
hat darauf bestanden die nachwuchs
factor wieder einzuführen mit dem die
rentenerhöhung jetzt gekürzt meine damen
und herren bei einer inflation von
aktuell 7,9 prozent darf es diese
kürzung nicht geben
und im kommenden jahr werden kürze von
der fdp dafür sorgen dass die
rentenanpassung von ursprünglich
erwarteten 5,4 prozent auf 2,9 prozent
zusammengestrichen werden wird die
grünen bejubeln dies und die spd macht
gute miene zum bösen spiel
menschen die 45 jahre lang gearbeitet
und durchschnittlich verdient haben
werden deshalb im kommenden jahr 200
euro netto und ab juli 20 23 über 400
euro netto im jahr weniger an rente
erhalten ich weiß künftig wird ein
sprunghaftes auf und ab bei den
rentenanpassungen und nullrunden
vermieten aber mit ihrem gesetzentwurf
werden der rentenversicherung in den
kommenden vier jahren 18 milliarden euro
fehlen geld das die rentnerinnen und
rentner dringend bräuchten denn die
rente muss zum leben reichen
warum streichen sie alle
kürzungsfaktoren aus der rentenanpassung
formel damit die renten wieder den
löhnen folgen lieber amt in ihrem
gesetzentwurf der heutigen und künftigen
rentnerinnen und rentnern die
rentenerhöhungen kürzt wird die linke
nicht zustimmen vom jahr
2000 bis 20 21 sind die löhne um fast 50
prozent gestiegen die renten aber noch
nicht einmal um 38 prozent darum
brauchen wir höhere renten stimmen sie
uns am änderungsantrag zu und erhöhen
sie das mindest rentenniveau von 48%
sofort auf 50 und dann schrittweise auf
53% das fordert der dgb das fordern alle
sozialverbände und die
rentenversicherung hat uns bestätigt
dass das auch finanzierbar ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
koalition krank darf nicht arm machen
und darum ist es gut dass menschen die
zwischen 21 und 28 10 wegen krankheit
frühzeitig in eine
erwerbsminderungsrente gehen muss nun
pauschale zuschläge erhalten höchste
zeit den durchschnittlich erhalten sie
nur 869 euro netto liebe appel die
richtung stimmt aber sie bleiben auf
halbem wege stehen wir linken fordern
die zuschläge auf 8 und 13 com sind zu
helfen das ist mein doppelte sehr wohl
frau präsidentin mein letzter satz ihre
halben zuschläge sollen erst in zwei
jahren ausgezahlt werden das ist
sozialer kälte pur frei nach rudi
carrell und schuld daran ist nur die fdp
herzlichen dank
auf matthias birkwald antwort ich kann
die fdp zumindest laut rindern ist nicht
mehr aber es könnte ihr
koalitionspartner die spd in kiel
beschließen heute ein gutes rennen paket
trotz aller kritik die ich auch in der
einen oder anderen stelle habe und
deswegen ist das ein guter tag für die
rentnerinnen und rentner es gibt die
höchste erhöhung seit jahrzehnten
und das ist ein grund zur freude
allerdings für die ziffer 3 millionen
bestandsrentner bei der em rente es ist
nicht unbedingt ein grund zum jubeln
denn auch sage ich nachdem wir fast 2
oder über zwei legislaturperioden mit
ihnen von der cdu meine damen und herren
gerungen haben und nichts für die
bestandsrentner erreicht haben bin ich
heute froh dass es endlich gelungen ist
es ist so erstrecken dass es endlich
gelungen ist auch für die im rentner im
bestand etwas zu tun
glh suchen sich ihr schicksal nicht aus
eine im wald ist keine rente die man
sich aussucht und die man auch nicht
verdient bekommt sondern die einen das
schicksal eben dann zuweist indem man
nämlich krank wird oder sich verletzt
hat und deswegen in eine em rente fällt
und das sind rentnerinnen und rentner
die zum teil wenig rente das sind die
ärmeren rentner von denen wir hier immer
sprechen ich deswegen sage ich es ist
gut dass wir jetzt endlich ein nachteil
ausgleich hinbekommen für die vielen
erwerbsminderungsrentner im bestand aber
leider lieber fdp muss sich da auch
sagen die anerkennung von schulz hätte
besser ausfallen können indem man mich
früher und mehr den bestandsrentner und
zugestanden hätten und das wäre möglich
gewesen
durch weitere maßnahmen des gesetzes
haben wir nicht keine wesentlichen
ausgabenerhöhungen nachher bei der
rentenkasse wir hätten unterm schnitt
unterm strich immer noch weniger wie
bisher ausgezahlt das muss man sich mal
auf der zunge zergehen lassen und das
ist auch in der anhörung deutlich
nochmal hervorgerufen worden und
deswegen wiederhole ich trotzdem es ist
insgesamt ein gutes renten paket mit
deutlichen verbesserung und wir sind ja
heute machen renten paket 1 und ich
freue mich auch drauf wenn wir dann beim
rennen paket zwei das dann folgen muss
wieder in diskussion einsteigen und dann
hoffentlich auch weitere verbesserungen
auch für die rentnerinnen und rentner im
bestand bei der erwerbsminderungsrente
hinbekommen mir ist aber ein anderes
anliegen genauso wichtig und zwar möchte
ich ermöglichen dass menschen länger und
fit im berufsleben bleiben und deswegen
müssen wir auch über reha maßnahmen
weiter sprechen das habe ich bereits
schon mehrfach hier gesagt und das
gehört auch zu einem renten paket das
wir hier künftig auf den weg bringen ich
wiederhole noch einmal heute ein guter
tag für die rentnerinnen und rentner für
uns aber der ansporn einmal einen
weiteren retten paket weiterzuarbeiten
herzlichen dank aus
für die unionsfraktion spricht nun
twittert auch er sitzt im ausschuss für
arbeit und soziales
frau präsidentin wert ihre kolleginnen
und kollegen kaum ein anderes thema ist
für die menschen in unserem land so
wichtig wie die rente zum einen weil die
rente natürlich darüber maßgeblich
bestimmt welchen lebensstandard sich die
menschen leisten können im alter und zum
anderen aber auch weil die rente die
anerkennung für die eigene
lebensleistung ist und deshalb sage ich
ganz offen freuen wir uns als union
darüber dass wir heute die renten so
kräftig erhöhen können denn das der
grund dass wir heute die renten erhöhen
können liegt an der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung von letzten jahr und die
haben cdu csu und spd geprägt meine
damen und herren das ist nicht das
ergebnis der ampel politik
und das zeigt auch dass wir als große
koalition die wirtschaft und die
gesellschaft in die unternehmen hier
durch die korona krise gut gebracht
haben und auch die 20 millionen
rentnerinnen grenzen heute von dieser
guten politik profitieren und wir finden
es wir finden es auch richtig dass die
erwerbsminderungsrente verbessert werden
und die bei herr kollege klar ist nicht
richtig dass wir nichts gemacht haben
wir haben gemeinsam zwei verbesserungs
gesetze bei der erwerbsminderungsrente
gemacht und
und diese de galten leider nicht für die
bestandsveränderung und rennt und das
wird heute nachgeholt wir hätten uns
durchaus gefreut wenn der minister auch
in der letzten legislaturperiode
eingesetzt so führen davor da
präsentiert hätte hatte aber leider
nicht und deshalb wird das heute
nachgeholt allerdings drängt sich schon
ein bisschen der verdacht auf sie
konnten in der anhörung nicht erklären
warum es viereinhalb und siebenmal
prozent sind sie scheinen hier schon ein
bisschen politik nach kassenlage zu
machen das hat jetzt ja auch gerade der
letzte redner hier von der spd deutlich
gemacht dass die fdp will da blockiert
hat und trotzdem kann ich ihnen nicht
ersparen einiges jetzt an wasser in den
wein rhein zu kippen
wenn sie die erwerbsminderungsrente
verbessern dann werden in zukunft einige
menschen aus der grundsicherung
herauskommen das ist gut für die
grundsicherung zahlt der staat die rente
aber zahlen die versicherten sie
entlasten also den staat zu lasten der
versichertengemeinschaft zu lasten der
rentenkasse und zum dank greifen sie
auch noch zusätzlich in die rentenkasse
ein indem sie den zuschuss den
steuerzuschuss für die grundrente
streichen von zwei milliarden euro hat
sogar der dgb kritisiert und da muss ich
ihnen sagen das belastet die
rentenversicherung erheblich sie blühen
dann damit die rentenkasse und das hat
nichts mit enkel gerechter politik zu
tun liebe fdp
und wenn ich schon mal der fdp bin sie
freuen sich wahnsinnig über ihren
nachholfaktor den wieder einzuführen
also auf deutschland die löhne sinken
müsste eigentlich die rente sind das
will man natürlich nicht deshalb wird es
mit einer zu künftigen rentenerhöhungen
verrechnet so weit die theorie aber die
praxis ist doch etwas ernüchternd denn
dieser nachholfaktor den sie heute
einführen greift exakt ein einziges mal
warum zum einen weil sie ihn schon 2025
wieder abschaffen und zum anderen zum
anderen weil sie bis dahin das
rentenniveau auf 48 prozent festsetzen
nur mit dem nachholfaktor wäre
wahrscheinlich das rentenniveau unter
die 48 prozent gefallen und deshalb wird
eben dieser nachholfaktor überschrieben
von ihrem gesetz und da muss ich lieber
sagen frau frau schulz sie feiern sich
als fdp dafür für ein jahr
ordnungspolitisch saubere rentenpolitik
zu machen nur um dann drei jahre lang
ihre enkel gerechte generation politik
ihre enkel gerechte rentenpolitik über
bord zu schmeißen das hat nichts mit
vorausschauender politik zu tun
sie haben von der fdp mit zitronen
gehandelt sind auch gelb ich gebe es zu
aber sie sind ziemlich sauer und
ungenießbar und ich sage was ich mir
gewünscht hätte ja ich hatte mir
gewünscht dass sie den berichten
kommissionen aus der letzten
legislaturperiode sich mal vorgenommen
heißt und so weit ich weiß hat die ein
gewisser minister hubertus heil
eingesetzt so weit ich weiß ist immer
noch mitglied der bundesregierung und da
stehen einige kluge dinge drin die sie
hätten heute machen können zum beispiel
eine haltelinie für 7 bzw 15 jahre fest
schreiben können und zwar nicht nur für
das rentenniveau sondern auch für das
für die beitragssätze das machen sie
eben nicht sie hätten sich über die
mindestrücklage kümmern könnten die
weiter zu glätten sie hätten sich darum
kümmern können dass wir mal einen
gesamtblick eine gesamt vorausschau
haben über alle
sozialversicherungsbeiträge die gezahlt
werden müssen und sie hätten auch die
betriebliche altersvorsorge stärken
können nichts davon greifen sie auf sie
blicken sich lediglich die haltelinie
gab es beim rentenniveau aber damit
zeigen sie was sie von ihrer eigenen
kommission halten herr nichts und so
will schaffen sie kein vertrauen in eine
zukünftige
rentenreform und der letzte
rettungsanker ist nun mal jetzt die
aktien rente sie wurde schon im
koalitionsvertrag von 100 milliarden auf
10 milliarden herunter geschreddert der
eigene finanzminister hat sie jetzt erst
der klasse beerdigt sie tauchen nämlich
nicht im haushalt auf und da frage ich
mich schon wie sie die eigentlich jetzt
noch finanzieren wollen machen sie dann
nochmal ein sondervermögen wir sind sehr
gespannt auf jeden fall reichen wir
ihnen gerne die hand wenn sie daran
interesse haben eine rentenreform zu
machen die über den nächsten wahltag
hinaus dauert dafür sind wir für
gespräche bereit wir freuen uns drauf
so sagt peter k und damit kommen wir zur
letzten rednerin in dieser debatte das
ist tanja machalet für die spd fraktion
und mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales die
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube nach dem tag heute
kann man sagen das war ein wirklich
guter tag für die menschen im land wir
haben heute morgen den mindestlohn
beschlossen wir beschließen jetzt das
erste renten paket mit einer deutlichen
erhöhung der renten mit 5,35 prozent im
westen 6,12 prozent im osten das ist die
stärkste rentenerhöhung seit fast
vierzig ja nur um das auch hier an der
stelle noch mal deutlich zu machen und
ich denke wir sind uns alle einig also
hier im haus wer sein leben lang
gearbeitet hat der muss sich auf die
rente verlassen können und genau das das
machen wir mit dem was wir hier vor
lägen deutlich und ich kann das was ich
heute morgen gesagt habe
mit blick auf die cdu zum thema rente
nur wiederholen weil kritiker sie haben
jetzt wieder viel gesagt aber sie haben
nicht gesagt dass sie wollen nein sie
haben gesagt wir haben nein sie haben
das kind den rest bericht verwiesen sie
haben auch die rechte so viel wie ich
erwarte von ihnen dass ihr klar sagen
welche renten die wohn möchten sie
sichern welchen beitrag möchten sie
sicher das haben sie hier nicht getan
war durch davor zu bald wieder voll sie
haben auch nicht der mit witz zum besten
fußballer geworden so lieh sie uns
vertraglich eine wortmeldung des
abgeordneten hubertus heil war sehr
gerne
nichts lieber als dass
wir sie so schön zusammen frau kollegin
könnten sie zur kenntnis nehmen ich
glaube ich spreche auch für meine
gesamte fraktion und auch die für den
mir bekannten
bundesarbeitsminister dass wir sehr sehr
gerne auf die cdu zu gehen wenn sie uns
bitte ihre finanzierungsvorschläge zur
rentenpolitik mir überreicht denn dazu
war nichts zu hören können sie
bestätigen dass wir das so sehen das
kann ich ausdrücklich so bestätigen
dankeschön und
der bundesarbeitsminister hat sich hier
eben in die reihen der abgeordneten
gesetzt weil er so dir das recht hat
eine kurze eine frage zu stellen als
arbeitsminister von der regierungsbank
dürfte er das nicht also hier ein
kleiner trick von hubertus heil
muss noch einmal festhalten das was wir
mit der erwerbsminderungsrente machen
dass wir das aus versicherung aus
versicherungs mittel finanzieren das ist
in der systematik vollkommen korrekt
weil nämlich die erwerbsminderungsrente
eine hohe leistungen der
rentenversicherung ist und nichts
anderes
ja wie gesagt also ich glaube dass heute
war ein guter tag für die menschen im
land wir haben stehen ja kurz vor
pfingsten da geht man natürlich auch
gerne mit den frohen botschaften ins
wochenende ich freue mich auf jeden fall
darauf wenn man all die diskussionen die
auch der kollege burgwald hier
aufgemacht hat also die werden wir
sicherlich dann auch beim paket 2 noch
intensiv führen wir haben ja noch das
mindest rücklagen gesetz aus ihrer
fraktion auch auf der tagesordnung also
wir haben noch einiges zu diskutieren
ich freue mich dann auf die konkreten
vorschläge der cdu fraktion sehr wird
wirklich doch wo ich mich drauf immer
die dann auch diskutieren können in
diesem sinne noch einmal vielen
herzlichen dank und ein schönes
wochenende
bis zur nächsten sitzungswoche
und ich schliesse die aussprache und
willkommen zur abstimmung über den von
der bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur rentenanpassung
2022 und zur verbesserung von leistungen
für den
erwerbsminderungsrente in bestand der
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
empfiehlt in seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache 20 74 den gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung auf den drucksachen
16 80 und 1974 in der ausschuss fassung
anzunehmen hierzu liegen drei
änderungsanträge vor wir beginnen mit
dem änderungsantrag der fraktion der
cdu/csu auf drucksache 20 83 wer stimmt
für diesen änderungsantrag
das ist die cdu csu und die fdp fraktion
und die fraktion die linke wer stimmt
dagegen ja in diesem änderungsantrag
fordert die union dass die
bundesregierung die sonderzahlung nicht
streichen sollte
abgelehnt wir kommen nun zum
änderungsantrag der fraktion die linke
auf drucksache 20 84 wer stimmt für
diesen antrag das ist die fraktion die
linke wer stimmt dagegen
ja und hier gab es einen änderungsantrag
der linksfraktion in dem sie fordert
dass der ausgleichsbedarf ausgesetzt er
wird
wir kommen zum änderungsantrag der
fraktion die linke auf drucksache 2085
wer stimmt für diesen änderungsantrag
dass die fraktion die linke wer stimmt
dagegen dass in die koalitionsfraktionen
und die fraktionen cdu/csu enthält sicht
ist die fdp-fraktion der änderungsantrag
ist damit abgelehnt
ich bitte nun diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
das ist die
koalitionsfraktionen das in den
koalitionsfraktionen und die cdu csu
fraktion und die fdp fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
er enthält sich das ist die auf die
fraktion die linke der gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter beratung angenommen wir
kommen unserer dritten beratung und zur
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen cdu
csu fraktion und fragt der fdp-fraktion
wer stimmt dagegen sie können sich
wieder hinsetzen
er stimmte dagegen wer enthält sich
das ist die fraktion die linke der
gesetzentwurf ist damit angenommen so
und hier gibt es ein bisschen am platz
das heißt die renten werden steigen wie
seit jahrzehnten nicht in ihrer lesung
sun trag der fraktion die linke auf
drucksache 20 86 abwehr stimmt für den
entschließungsantrag dass die fraktion
die linke wer stimmt dagegen die
koalitionsfraktionen und die cdu csu
fraktion während hält sich ist die
fdp-fraktion entschließungsantrag ist
damit abgelehnt
zum zusatzpunkt zwei interfraktionell
wird die überweisung der vorlage auf
drucksache 2034 an die in der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungs vorschläge das sehe ich
nicht dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen ich komme zurück zum
zusatzpunkt 4 und uns liegt das ergebnis
vor über die namentliche
schlussabstimmung zum gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung zur errichtung eines
sondervermögens
bundeswehr
abgegebene stimmen
680 mit ja haben gestimmt
593 mit nein haben bestimmt 80
enthaltungen 7 der gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen
so und damit ist auch die zweite
abstimmung heute zum sondervermögen
bundeswehr durch die linke auf
drucksache 21 33 wer stimmt dafür
dass ist die fraktion die linke wer
stimmt dagegen sind die
koalitionsfraktionen und die
cdu/csu-fraktion wer enthält sich dass
es die fdp-fraktion der
entschließungsantrag ist damit abgelehnt
wir sind damit am schluss unserer
heutigen tagesordnung ich berufe die
nächste sitzung des deutschen
bundestages ein auf mittwoch den 22
juni 13 uhr ich wünsche ihnen ein
gesegnetes pfingstfest und alles gute
kommen sie gut nach hause die sitzung
ist geschlossen und damit verabschieden
wir uns auch mit unserer übertragung von
dieser haushaltswoche in dieser woche
wurde ja sehr viel geld beschlossen
95 79 milliarden euro sollen ausgegeben
werden in diesem jahr soll eine
neuverschuldung von
138 9 4 milliarden euro geben und wie
wir es ja dann auch eben noch einmal
gehört haben haben die abgeordneten
zugestimmt zum sondervermögen bundeswehr
das grundgesetz wird geändert so haben
es hier die abgeordneten mit einer
zweidrittelmehrheit beschlossen und
jetzt eben haben sie auch noch dem
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
zugestimmt wie dieses sondervermögen
eingesetzt wird und auch schon erste
erste details wie dann diese ganzen
schulden getilgt werden sollen